Solar systems follow a pretty generic recipe.
To begin, combine hydrogen, helium, oxygen,
and carbon into a cloud of gas and dust.
Sprinkle with magnesium, iron and silicon.
Spin until the cloud forms a star and a planetary disk.
Wait 10 million years,
or until lumps form in the disk.
And voila!
[snap]
You’ve baked a solar system.
But the planets we’ve found
orbiting other stars
are very different from the ones
in our own solar system.
So, the recipes for cooking up an exoplanet
are probably pretty different
from those for baking an Earth.
Okay, so you’ve got a star.
It contains a list of all the chemical ingredients
that the planet has to work with.
Those proportions vary from planet to planet,
and astronomers are still trying to figure out
what factors produce a rocky planet
versus a gassy one.
Mixing matters, too.
Some planetary disks are more turbulent than others.
And where different elements end up in the mix
determines whether or not they end up in a planet.
When the planet forms also makes a big difference.
Gas giants need a lot of prep time.
They have to form a rocky core
before they can start collecting vapors,
so they start baking soon after their star forms.
[ringing kitchen timer]
Small, rocky planets can start later.
How far a planet forms in relation to its star
complicates planetary recipes.
Small planets that form too close to a star
can lose their atmospheres
to energetic winds from the star.
Sometimes big planets may arise at the system’s edges
but finish cooking closer to their star later on.
That’s one way to make oddballs
like hot versions of Jupiter or Neptune.
Scientists are studying exactly how these variables
influence planet formation in other systems.
And NASA’s latest planet-hunting satellite TESS
could reveal clues to exotic exoplanet compositions.
Meanwhile, researchers are cooking up
experimental planets in the lab,
to try to understand how other systems formed.
[music]
[snap]
So one day, baking an exoplanet
will be a piece of cake.
[ music]